oi eu fui fã eu fui convidado a falar
hoje aqui no ted porque infringe a lei
eu sou um trator do código no artigo 163
do código penal brasileiro dano ao
patrimônio público
mas o que algumas pessoas podem ver isso
como dano ao patrimônio público eu vejo
algo comum pela cidade como zé roberto
está motivado
desde criança quando tinha o sonho de
querer mudar o mundo e eu acredito que é
assim é possível criar novas percepções
e sóis nas cidades onde nós vivemos
porque muitas vezes o nosso dia-a-dia
nosso dia a dia as pessoas caminham elas
correm em busca do seu futuro e busca o
seu trabalho eo planejamento da cidade
tem muito a ver com isso
nós esquecemos que nós podemos observar
além da nossa frente
além das suas além das calçadas nós
podemos ter uma outra percepção da
cidade isso muita influência no
planejamento das cidades que desde a
revolução industrial
elas têm sido planejadas de uma forma
linear uma forma padronizada focalizando
sempre um desempenho e progresso
voltadas para que as pessoas saiam de
casa e vão para o trabalho sai de casa
para escola e volta em menor tempo
possível para que tudo corra
completamente todo mundo trabalhe etc ea
gente acaba esquecendo que sim é
possível criar novas percepções nas
cidades
isso acaba fazendo com que nós não
esquecemos que as cidades elas realmente
foram planejadas foram feitas para as
pessoas não para máquinas não para
carros
as pessoas só pessoas que fazem a cidade
fazer cidade acontecer
e sim é possível fazer algo que
realmente mude a percepção da cidade que
a altere o estilo das cidades estamos
acostumados a escutar todos os dias
informações você clamam da vida reclamam
no trabalho reclama da família reclama
do mundo e está muito acostumado a
escutar muitas reclamações todos os dias
quando trabalhava e estudava e no ensino
médio principalmente com os colegas a
não querer nada com nada
professores reclamam da educação ainda
mais que eu moro no brasil é muito fácil
reclamar e tem muitas coisas e
reclamados e claro mas uma coisa que
sempre notei foi que as pessoas que mais
reclamam em sua maioria são as que não
fazem nada para mudar isso
certo dia eu estava navegando na
internet proporcionando produtiva etc
quando conheci o show de chi que é um
grupo de coletivo urbano que fazem
intervenções urbanas em porto alegre
esse cara realmente mudaram a cidade de
porto alegre criando intervenções e
propunham am novas interpretações
mobiliários urbanos tendo com sensações
com motivos nos mais diversos como esse
da lixeira conseguiu posicionar
mostrando de lixeiras porque as pessoas
às vezes não chegam os cheiros elas
jogam lixo no chão e presta é algo
cultural isso como esse que foi contada
pra conscientiza as pessoas fumaram
cigarro porque isso mata todo mundo né
não
o muro onde tocaram num caça palavras
das pessoas que estavam passando o seu
dia a dia no trabalho na escola electrão
elas iam lá pegar uns dias que tinha
pendurado dinho ali e se achava as
palavras que poderiam ser a mudar o dia
delas como rã palavras são encontrados
ali e no momento que eu conheci esses
caras eu pensei caramba que coisa legal
porque ia fazer isso aqui no fundo sabe
isso é uma coisa tão legal eles utilizam
do das idéias da criatividade pra criar
uma nova percepção visual do tas
cansados
loomis dos muros das duas placas e
propondo uma ideia nova uma arma um novo
modo de ver o mundo e querendo críticas
e novas idéias que podem mudar o hábito
das pessoas e pode mudar o hábito da
cidade como um todo
eu pensei sou de massa
espero fazer isso aqui né eu tava eu
tinha 16 17 anos naquela época estava no
ensino médio
e foi assim que eu pensei depois eu
fiquei um ano sem pensar nisso de novo
sabe eu pensei não vou fazer isso não
vai ser no ensino médio tem só 16 anos
deixou um publicitário algum
universitário resolva isso veja isso tem
essa inspiração que eu tive
e faça isso nesse momento foi que eu dei
a primeira barreira que foi eu eu te amo
meu estimado
e aí eu fiquei um ano pensando nisso deu
acabei deixando para lá que eu ensino
médio eu conheci mais pessoas que também
tinham esse pensamento de querer fazer
algo diferente de querer fazer algo
inovador ao objetivo assim
e daí eu eu realmente senti eu vi que
ele estava sozinho nessa que tinha mais
pessoas que também tinha esse mesmo
pensamento de fazer algo diferente algo
que impactassem uma forma criativa e que
fosse bom para a cidade e as pessoas
como um todo e aí já temos amigos os
ânimos e resolveu botar em prática a
primeira intervenção o que nós chamamos
de calma de uma lixeira de perto
luiz gabriel amigos fez 11 assistências
onde nós tivemos calma tem cheiro de
perto o drama us 163 e saímos em um
domingo de manhã pra sair espalhando
mensagens no chão
o objetivo com essa intervenção foi
lembrar às pessoas que existem cheias na
cidade porque parece que algo tão
difícil é alguém botar comprar uma bala
não jogar bola no chão o papel da banca
no chão ou é tão antigamente quando você
pegar uma bala como economia bala não
jogava no chão esse estranho porque todo
mundo fazer
isso e era tão incomum que pegar e botar
no bolso botar em um lixo mesmo na
lixeira pública
vou fazer pra casa botar lá chega em
casa e nós resolvemos lembrar às pessoas
que sim existem lixeiras e elas podem
fazer isso e nós espalhamos um domingo
de manhã e falhamos nas calçadas pela
cidade em pontos estratégicos de
movimentação paradas de ônibus avenidas
e giz foi um domingo de manhã porque era
um dia que não tem pessoas na rua nas
ruas ninguém sai no domingo de manhã
para passear muito difícil alguém quiser
domingo de manhã e passear é um bom dia
para dormir ninguém sai né então é
porque a gente estava com receio a gente
não sabia conhecer a reação das pessoas
quando a gente fazer isso já sabia se
elas iam pensar nossa que legal ou seja
vamos falar com a polícia o avião só
denunciar processar a gente só com
receio que isso tudo só que aconteceu
uma coisa muito louca que depois a gente
fez a intervenção
a repercussão dela foi muito louca na
cidade tipo sai uma notícia no jornal na
rádio na tv e nós vimos que realmente
nós tínhamos passado essa mensagem ea
mensagem de conciliação tinha sido
expandida
o máximo que nós queremos realmente
aquele assistência e ajudava a gente tem
a nossa cara legal de uma reflexão vamos
continuar fazendo algo que a gente
continue fazendo ea gente pensou em
outra causa e mostra motivação dessa vez
o estresse no trânsito onde nós
propúnhamos novas mensagens novas e
leitura das placas de pare
nesse momento tão gostoso tão legal que
é o trânsito é quem é que não gosta de
estar no trânsito
a gente criou adesivos com mensagens do
tipo para e sorria faria bra se não pára
de sonhar porque ninguém é de ferro né
tem uma zequinha
só que esse projeto essa intervenção
teve uma repercussão um pouco diferente
do que na primeira
nós estamos sendo acusados de causar
vandalismos
e essa alteração na placa estava sendo
as pessoas falam que isso poderia causar
acidentes
as pessoas viam era engraçado falar né
porque o toque de pele tem um formato
único né no tribunal é vermelha e tem
sido em grande parte o e daí a gente
imaginou como seria isso nas pessoas e
um para o carro em movimento e um saiu
do carro para alguém causando o acidente
ou eu começar a olhar a placa e eu
começar a sorrir e um casal acidente ou
ela ia começar a sonhar perdeu o volante
perdeu o controle causando um acidente e
é óbvio que não aconteceu né eu espero
que num e ainda seguindo essa lógica de
usar por bana com uma forma de protesto
também uma forma de uma forma criativa
de divulgar uma idéia ou uma nova
percepção durante alguma coisa ou um
olhar urbano alguma idéia nós pensamos
ram o que melhora o trânsito da cidade o
que não ocupa espaço nas ruas o que faz
bem para a saúde não gastar gasolina
econômico e saudável patinete
não sei se é melhor não bicicleta
discreta
a gente pensou é já que a cidade tem uma
ciclovia agora né pra que ele passou no
tenha suas próprias bonitinhos aqui
pensa em divulgar a bicicleta com uma
forma de locomoção até para melhorar o
trânsito da cidade o fluxo do trânsito
porque o trânsito aqui sabe como é que é
aquela que sabe aquela que nem queira
saber também que a gente fez a fizemos
umas placas cerca de 20 placas
utilizando discos de vinil spray um
boletim pan essência nós espalhamos
essas placas pela cidade em pontos de
grande movimentação para ter uma maior
visibilidade das pessoas
duas pessoas que estavam no ônibus ou
carros pra poder sim divulgar essa idéia
é implantar na cabeça das pessoas que
bicicleta é um método legal é um direito
legal de se transportar e tudo mais
como esse tipo mais baixos menos fumaça
vai de bike mais likes mais saúde e
vamos chegar lá disse
só que eu não tô aqui só para falar
sobre intervenções urbanas que vai falar
sobre os desafios e barreiras
nós enfrentamos todos os dias diante de
idéias novas ou de um negócio novo que
nós queremos investir ou em uma
oportunidade nova ou algo que nós
podemos fazer que vai causar um impacto
diferente na cidade as pessoas ou só em
você mesmo assim que nós iniciamos a
fazer assentar essas intervenções na
cidade muitas pessoas questionavam a
gente com perguntas do tipo por que
vocês fazem isso são temas que fazer
isso num caixote e é certo que não
estavam presentes
e aí eu percebi que muito muitas coisas
que nos impedem que não se prive fazer
algo novo e fazer algo que pode
realmente causar uma diferença na gente
no mundo nas pessoas ao nosso redor
são essas barreiras do pensamento que
nós mesmos temos que é essa é só esse
receio do que as pessoas vão pensar
sobre nós sobre a gente está fazendo
isso o que as pessoas vão pensar sobre
isso que ela não falar sobre isso e como
afunda na cidade consideravelmente
pequena tem 200 mil habitantes no
interior do estado três semanas era o
considerado diferente normal algo muito
estranho na cidade
e daí o veículo estava em julgamento
também o tipo as casas que chama a
atenção diz trindade de atenção
deixa eles bobinhos só que na verdade
não era isso né
eu também pude perceber que a questão de
mudança do mundo inicia muito antes
muito muito muito além disso de criar
intervenções urbanas é claro é muito
fácil você basta querer ter uma idéia
é um problema você vai lá propõe algo
diferente encontra pessoas que também
têm essa idéia
você já elabora alguma coisa e fazem
isso porque uma coisa que eu pude
aprender sobre depois de todos tanto
tempo fazendo intervenções urbanas e
projetos nas ruas da cidade
é que assim que você sai da sua zona de
conforto
assim que você sabe essa bolha assim que
você você sair dessa e levantando
realmente a bunda do sofá e vai fazer
algo prático e algo que tem uma
diferença
você não quer mais voltar com esse é um
ciclo vicioso se sabe e mas para isso é
preciso dar o primeiro passo
de nada adianta ficar reclamando do
mundo ficar reclamando da cidade da vida
ou dos estudos se você não fizer nada
pra querer mudar isso
para tentar mudar isso se você quiser
mudar o mundo mude sua forma de pensar
seja a diferença se desafia faça algo
novo mas para isso é preciso mudar o
mundo que existe em cada um de vocês